c'est un éternel sujet de débat
tradition ancestrale pour les uns
pratiques barbares pour les autres de
plus en plus d'associations réclament
l’interdiction de la chasse l'argument
principal les accidents seraient en
augmentation la chasse tuerait et mutile
Ray de plus en plus de personnes alors
est-ce vrai que disent les chiffres la
réponse dans facture
tout d'abord le nombre d'accidents de
chasse les chiffres ici sont très clairs
selon l'Office français de la
biodiversité chargée de l'organisation
de l'examen du permis de chasser et de
sa délivrance pour le compte de l'État
la moyenne du nombre d'accidents mortels
ou non est en baisse constante depuis 20
ans depuis 2000 date à laquelle l'ofb a
commencé à partager ses bilans 3415
personnes ont déjà été victimes
d'accidents de chasse la période la plus
meurtrière la saison 2003 2004 a
comptabilisé 203 victimes dont 29 morts
sur la période 2021 2022 de septembre à
septembre l'ofb a recensé 95 accidents
de chasse c'est une augmentation par
rapport à la saison précédente qui avait
fait 80 victimes dont sept mortels mais
cette hausse ne reflète pas la tendance
générale qui est à la baisse depuis 20
ans
on est quand même sur la deuxième année
consécutive où on a moins de 100
accidents dans l'année on est
aujourd'hui vraiment sur des chiffres
très bas et donc le moindre accident
supplémentaire peut faire basculer la
tendance ceci étant la tendance depuis
20 ans elle est vraiment vers la baisse
ça reste encore 5 accident de trop
l'objectif qui a été fixé à l'OM ou
l'ofb c'est bien entendu zéro accident
on travaille là-dessus pour améliorer
toutes les règles de sécurité c'est le
nombre d'accidents s'amenuisent reste
que la chasse inquiète de plus en plus
de Français en effet ce sentiment
d'insécurité se reflète dans les
sondages selon une enquête Ipsos 87% des
Français estiment que la chasse pose un
problème pour les promeneurs car les
chiffres peuvent donner des raisons
d'être inquiets lors de la saison 2021
2022 la pratique a fait 25 victimes chez
les non-chasseurs dont deux morts ci
blessés gravement et 17 légèrement en
proportion 26% des victimes d'accident
n'était pas chasseurs c'est un chiffre
largement au-dessus de la moyenne sur 20
ans qui est de 12%. les incidents liés à
la chasse qui ne cause pas des dégâts
humains mais matériels sont en
augmentation et aussi si le FB a reçu 94
fiches concernant ces incidents lors de
la saison 2020-2021 elle en comptabilise
104 lors de la saison 2021 2022 cela
représente une augmentation de plus de
10% sur ces 104 incidents on en observe
53 concernant les tirs vers les
habitations 33 vers les véhicules et 18
sur des animaux domestiques
sur les 10 dernières années la moyenne
serait de 97 incidents par an si l'on
compare donc cette moyenne avec ses 104
incidents il s'agit là d'une
augmentation de près de 7%. on reçoit
des plaintes des propriétés privées qui
ne sont pas respectées des distances pas
respectées des insultes des altercations
et je peux vous avouer que depuis les
annonces qui ont été faites par le
gouvernement là depuis trois jours le
téléphone n'arrête pas de sonner on est
débordé de moins en moins d'accidents de
chasse de mortel c'est vrai il y en a
encore en plus ça impacte beaucoup les
chasseurs mais il y a une insécurité qui
fait que les gens sont plus sortir je
pense que les incidents vont se
multiplier parce qu'en plus parce qu'il
y a une saturation il y en a un
ras-le-bol quoi les gens ils sortent ils
vont il faut aller se balader ça y est
une battue ici on peut pas y aller il
repart il y a aucune possibilité d'avoir
des informations sur sur les jours de
nançage sur les territoires parce que
c'est pas
harmoniser contrairement à certaines
idées reçues et si l'on s'en réfère aux
chiffres les accidents liés à la chasse
ne sont pas en augmentation de manière
générale ces dernières années seule la
saison dernière a connu une hausse par
rapport à la précédente cependant la
proportion de non chasseurs impactés par
ces accidents liés à la chasse à Bondy
lors de la dernière saison reste à voir
cependant si c'est os sont une exception
dans un contexte de baisse général des
accidents et des incidents liés à la
chasse ou si elle annonce un changement
profond et inquiétant sur le long terme
[Musique]